Before I start on the today's topic,
which is a Greek tyranny.
I have been asked to say a word on the subject.
Well,
to answer the question really the best I can.
If the hoplite Phalanx was so stunningly successful in the period of the fifth,
sixth,
fifth,
fourth centuries BC,
why was it that other people's,
other than the Greeks,
the ones who came in contact with them and saw it and were victimized by it,
why didn't they adopted?
Well,
let me make it perfectly clear,
like all other,
all the other interesting questions in this course.
I cannot give you a firm answer.
I can only give you a opinions and it,
but that whole subject now is so wonderfully more controversial than it was,
uh,
probably ever before in history.
Because everything now in history that bears on the Western world and its
relations with some other world is part of a great political assault by those
people who are eager to pull down anything that seems to be admirable or special
or positive about the west and either to say,
um,
it really was bad or to say it wasn't so terrific or it didn't exist.
Uh,
so that's the context in which,
not the student's question,
but the,
the larger question is getting kicked around these days.
Well,
I think part of the reason for unhappiness about it is that I think the answer
lies in the character precisely of the Polis.
The fact that it had,
uh,
an ethos,
a set of values which placed so powerfully at the center of the minds of the
citizens.
The notion that the combination of courage in a military setting,
which was the inheritance from homer and the new ideology of devotion to the
Polis as the most important kind of commitment that a citizen could have
produced a an attitude which was that it was the job of a man who was a citizen
of a Polis beyond anything else to fight bravely in the ranks of his army.
And as it happened that they developed,
I think this latter part of the story is simply accidental.
They di,
they happen to develop this technique which employed the weapons and defensive
armor that they had.
And then because they had those things,
and because this ethos was present,
it was possible to put together this fighting unit,
which was the Phalanx which depended so enormously,
heavily upon the commitment to the commonality to the common cause that was
characteristic of the Polis.
Now,
every state of every kind,
every people,
every tribe,
they have some degree of this kind of commitment to one another or else they
wouldn't exist as a unit.
But there are really very sharp differences of degree in terms of how powerfully
this commitment really affects people.
Uh,
you might even find that in the set you would find in the same people at
different times in their history.
The power of this idea and this commitment and it's so beyond an idea somehow
it's sort of really bred and trained into the bones of every Greek man in the
Polis beginning sometime,
I would say in the seventh century or earlier and carrying forward so long as
the Polis remained an autonomous and independent unit.
So if you looked at it,
weeks against Persians is the best case we have because the Greeks,
what the Persians more than they fought other non-Greek peoples and the Persians
were very formidable.
Let's remember the Persians had defeated every other power there was in the
world that they knew and,
and uh,
controlled and dominated a vast,
vast empire by anybody's standards.
But certainly by the standards of the world in which they knew.
So for the Greeks to defeat the Persians,
there was nothing routine about that that was always going to be surprising and
needing explanation.
So really a way to focus the question that I'm addressing is how come the
Persians didn't do it?
And there I think then that case,
the answer was not so very hard because the Persian empire was a composite unit
made up of lots of places and vast numbers of people who had been conquered by
the Persians and whose relationship to the great king of Persia was really in
almost technical sense that of slaves they needed to do.
They had to do,
they were expected to do whatever the Persian king told him to do.
Now,
he was not a fanatical and,
and he,
he did not make requests that typically were impossible for people to do.
Uh,
in fact,
his,
the Persian rule over there,
a conquered peoples was in many ways easier and more generous and less intrusive
than other people's.
Uh,
for instance,
in the realm of religion,
the Persians did not bother,
didn't interfere with people's exercise of religion.
Those of you who have read a book called the Old Testament,
will remember that,
uh,
the person show up at important places and they get treated very nicely.
Uh,
there are,
there's a bad Persian or two here or there,
but he gets put down.
Uh,
but the Persians treat and the Persians were among the people who treated the
Jews very well because they didn't care what the Persian,
what the Jews did in their religious life.
So long as they did the two important and essential things as the Persians
required,
which was you had to do military service for the king at his demand and you had
to pay taxes.
If you did those things and made no trouble.
That's all.
That's all you had to worry about from the Persians.
Well,
okay,
why didn't the Persians then adopted pop?
Because the greater part of their army wasn't Persian.
Even.
So the kinds of,
uh,
allegiance that's necessary for this kind of fighting wasn't motivated by most
of these people.
A second reason was the Persians themselves and their Arion ally's the Medes had
achieved their success militarily as cavalryman.
And that was their nature.
And that was what they practiced an elevated to the highest levels so that the
best Persians fought in the cavalry.
They had infantry and some of their infantry was relatively very good,
but there wasn't that kind of all that matters in a polls.
Basically,
I'm exaggerating,
only very slightly is how you fight in the infantry.
And it happily,
that question isn't so bad because when we get to the story of the Spartans,
which comes after our story of the tyrants,
I will read to you some of the poetry which was the material with which Spartans
were trained.
And you'll quickly see why,
uh,
the Greek ethos,
the Greek feeling of absolute commitment,
voluntary,
absolute commitment,
even at the risk of your life for the Polis was the central most important force
in society.
So the answer is essentially a moral commitment based upon training.
And a belief is why the Greeks did the,
uh,
fail and plus the historical accident of there.
Having developed that technique,
it should be pointed out that there were peoples in the ancient near east before
the Greeks ever came to be anything who had closely ordered a armed infantry
soldiers.
The Assyrians are a very good example.
But if you examine a Syrian fighting,
it's not quite the same thing as the Greek fighting.
Uh,
and if I knew more about a Syrian fighting,
I might be able to say still more.
I don't know how much is actually known in detail,
but there was obviously an element in the story which went beyond merely
equipment and order and so on.
It had to do with what was in their heads.
And I think,
you know,
if you know about warfare in the modern world,
even right today,
so much of how of what determines whether armies succeed or fail in their
missions has to do with what's in their head.
Every army I think let's,
let's say every good army even,
um,
is good at certain things and they are trained and their culture prepares them
if they are successful to do certain kinds of things,
if you take them and make them fight in a different way until they are able to
make an adjustment,
which is sometimes never,
they can't fight with that same skill.
And so there was a very close union I would say,
and I'll come back at home with to say a smarter guy than I said it long ago.
Um,
does it,
there's some close connection between the nature of the society that produces
and uses the military force and the kind of fighting that military force can do.
Uh,
I'm really just giving you a little riff on a tune written by Aristotle back in
his day when he connects closely the character,
I think I mentioned that the other day,
the character of a regime and the character of the fighting,
I did tell you about that.
You know,
if it's going to be a cavalry based,
it's going to be ours to cratic or oligarchic if it's going to be a naval base
is going to be democratic and so on and so forth.
So I hope that's of some help in dealing with that question.
Let's turn out precisely to this phenomenon,
which is Greek tyranny.
Tyranny emerges in the seventh century.
BC may be,
it might've,
no,
I think not anything before that.
And it,
uh,
it emerges,
I would think for many of the same reasons.
And in response to some of the very same developments that I described for you
and talking about the great burst of colonization that began in the eighth
century in the Greek world,
all of those tumultuous,
troubling changing forces that were at work in society where we're at work and
bringing about this new kind of regime,
which lasted from one to three generations,
uh,
among the Greeks before it faded away.
It was a transitional phase in Greek society rather than one that lasted for a
terribly long time,
but it was not a trivial.
And then as I say,
in some cases it went for three generations.
Okay.
What is tyranny?
Let's begin with the word the word tea run.
Neha is tyranny.
The word Tiran nos is tiring and etymologically that the word does is not a
Greek word.
It was a borrowed word that the Greeks took from somebody else and then applied
it to a certain elements that emerged in their society.
Chances are it was borrowed from Lydia that uh,
kingdom in Asia minor that was inland from the Greek settlements on the coast.
And the first Lydian king of whom we here,
uh,
that could fit as the first tyrant from Greek perspective was a man called guide
gs Gyg ges who ruled in Lydia per something like the years six 85,
two six 57,
something like that.
The first time the word tear on us or some version of it appears in Greek that
we have comes in,
the fragments of the poet are killing us.
And uh,
he is a fascinating character and we do have fortunately a few nice fragments of
his poetry.
In fact,
for the first time in the last couple of decades,
for the first time since they were lost,
we actually have a full lyric poem by,
uh,
our killer kiss.
But in any case,
he has this bit of poetry that is preserved in a late writers,
a collection which says,
I don't care for the wealth of golden guide.
Geez.
Nor have I ever envied him.
I am not jealous of the works of the gods.
And I have no desire for lofty tyranny.
This is where the word tyranny comes into the picture and even in that small
collection of words,
you get some idea of what the Greeks meant by tyranny.
They were talking about tremendous power from their perspective and it's golden
guide gs and that's not an accident.
They mean wealthy guide.
GS tyrants are people who have lots of wealth and lots of power and they also
rule in one translation that a poet's give for tyranny.
Those is for for lofty despotism.
That is he rules not as an equal,
he rules not as a legitimate king.
He rules as a master ruling slaves is the implication of that.
It is a,
it is.
It comes from the Greek perspective.
It comes from the east.
It is not native Greek.
It is something new.
In the Greek experience,
they haven't had kings like that even in their legends.
So that's going to be a central idea that surrounds the concept of tyranny.
The Greek word that comes closest to it,
but it doesn't do the same job is Monarchos outward monarch.
And that simply means a ruler.
Who is one,
a single ruler?
Well,
you know,
you need a word for that and in Greek because that's not the natural thing in
Greece.
As you know already,
every regime that we have discussed from the homer Homeric world on posts posts
a Bronze Age,
um,
shows multiple kings,
in,
in the Iliad,
the Odyssey,
yes,
there is the general list.
Some of you remember Agamemnon,
but everybody there is a king.
There's not just one king.
So that's,
that's the Greek way of looking at things.
Whereas the rest of the world,
and if the Greeks had only known anywhere,
you look in the rest of the world,
the typical regime is monarchy of one kind or another absolute power.
Nobody in Greece has absolute power in the Greek point of view,
but kings elsewhere too,
but is another sense that attaches for the Greeks to the word Tierra nos or
[inaudible].
And that is that the power is not legitimately acquired.
The Greeks could understand that there'd be somebody called the boss allows and
that the reason he was boss allows was that his father was,
and that the regime of that state is royal and this is a perfectly legitimate
regime.
The Greeks,
although they don't practice a kingship during the period that we studied,
uh,
they don't regard that as an illegitimate form of regime.
Kingship is legitimate.
Tyranny is not,
and I want to spell that out for you,
but before we get to my spelling it out for you,
let me just give it a few more of the characteristics that it comes to have by
classical times in the minds of the Greeks.
It is,
as I say,
despotically exercise is not legitimate and one aspect of it's not being
legitimate is that it is not responsible.
A K a t around us does not have to explain himself and nobody would dare insists
that he do.
He need not consult anybody if he doesn't want to.
He doesn't need to have the approval of anybody.
All of that makes him illegitimate.
Irresponsible is another word.
I think that fits into the picture because we shall see.
That's certainly by the classical period.
The Greeks felt any regime to be legitimate must be responsible in the technical
term since it must be answerable to somebody because all human beings was the
full philosophical core of this idea are not to be trusted by complete power.
They will abuse it.
They will abuse it with violence.
They will.
And that violence will very often mean sexual violence.
Uh,
but it will take every other form as well.
And uh,
let's go back to our killer kisses.
Few words,
which are so rich in telling us so much about it.
He says,
I am not jealous of the works of the gods.
What's that got to do with anything?
Well,
because the Greek view of tyranny was that tyrants.
And one of the things is wrong with tyrants is that they see themselves as
rivaling the gods as thinking themselves to be divine,
or at least thinking that they could act as though they were gods.
And because they have the power and the wealth and because they have no
responsibility to anybody.
Uh,
presumably they can.
And this is one of the things that makes them terrible because when they do,
it's this act of behaving as though they were gods is what the Greeks,
one of the things that the Greeks meant when they said Hubris,
this arrogant is violent,
arrogant kind of exercise of power.
Now on the that's that is the way things look fundamentally in the classical
period.
But even in the classical period,
there was a remnant of I,
but I think and most scholars I think would agree was the special characteristic
of the idea in its earlier days,
which was not so much how evil,
uh,
a tyranny was.
Because in the early days it's not clear that they thought it was,
but because of the fact that it was not legitimately acquired,
it was not part of the normal way things happen.
And I've mentioned this to you earlier,
the good example of that is eat a paas tear on us.
Oedipus the king.
He did notice it.
They don't usually,
nobody translates it eat IPIs the tyrants and their right not to do so because
it would mislead us way.
We use the word tiring.
It's always back.
There's no good tiring,
but uh,
it so that you will,
you will often see a translated Oedipus rex into the Latin.
But rex means king.
So Oedipus the king is okay and it actually,
it's not bad to say he just press rex because the,
the Romans had this idea that kings were bad.
So there's a little bit of that glittering around the age.
But for the Greeks that's not there at the beginning.
Okay.
Probably the contemporaries of guide gs and of the tyrants who came after him in
Greece probably didn't use the term yet,
probably sprang up,
uh,
at a later time.
But we can't be sure of that.
For the Greeks,
it originally meant something much more neutral without this great moral baggage
to carry with it.
It's simply meant more than anything else.
Two things.
One man rule.
Well,
I would always raise an eyebrow,
but you could imagine it being okay and the fact that it was unconstitutional,
it did not come about in a way that followed tradition,
which was what Greek constitutions were traditional sets of laws or customs.
Okay.
That's the general picture.
Let's take a look at tyranny as it emerges in Greece.
And,
uh,
we don't know very much about it.
Here's another one of these cases where we are dependent on later sources.
We have no,
I think I'm right in saying nothing really contemporary at all that speaks about
any tyrant.
Uh,
and so that's a problem,
but we have to deal with that.
And then there are very limited tails that are told about them so that we have
to piece together a lot of information and ask ourselves what does it all mean.
In any case,
the first tyrant named in the Greek tradition is a man called fight on of our
gos who is mentioned by Aristotle in his politics.
And he says some interesting things that come back and amend with here are some
of the facts or alleged facts that are,
that surround fight on in the Greek tradition.
One said,
oh,
I see.
He is the king of our gos and Argos,
you know,
in,
in the Homeric tradition is a very big,
powerful,
important place.
Our ghosts includes my Sini,
uh,
and all of that.
So this would be a king of a large and an important area that these are jives.
When a fight anonymous was a king of Argos were,
uh,
engaged in a conflict with Sparta as to who would be the dominant force in the
Peloponnesus.
And they fought a battle at a place called ECI in the year six 68 in which the
are jives under fight on defeated the Spartans and really defeated him.
Wasn't just a,
a little skirmish.
They were now the top dog as proven by the following other alleged facts about
what's going on here.
Fight on,
got himself elected chairman,
president of the Olympic festival.
That was a tremendous honor and it indicated deference to him and scholars
suggest if it really happened,
that would have suggested they were the Argos and fight on where the dominant
force in the Peloponnesus.
Um,
they,
uh,
and further evidence,
and this is really rather better evidence I think even than that is the fact I
don't hesitate to use that fact that a fight out of August apparently imposed a,
a system of uniform weights and
measures on the entire Peloponnesus.
And those remained the weights and measures employed in the Peloponnesus
thereafter.
So that a,
they were called the [inaudible] measures.
You don't do that if you're not in a effective control of the region.
Nothing is more basic than determining something like that.
So I think that lends considerable plausibility to the general story.
It is also said that he was a,
uh,
a leader of the army,
which was a hoplite army,
and that his success depended upon his successful leadership of the hoplite
army.
Well,
that fits in with one general interpretation that scholars have used about the
arise of tyrants.
It's nobody claims it's universal.
But one feature that seems to be plausibly present is that the new way of
fighting in the hoplite Phalanx,
which was to turn out to be decisive,
well that brought about that leaders who were very good leaders of hoplite
Phalanx is and should they decide to seize power,
uh,
in any state where they had been doing the leadership,
they could typically count on their army and the army they had led to assist
them all,
which makes obvious sense.
If you're going to get the best fighting force around and they like you and
you're popular and you want to be a boss,
that's your best shot.
So tradition also lends some small support to the idea that maybe that's how
fight on himself to the kingship of before I depart,
I just feel it necessary to make one small point.
I said weights and measures the,
there are elements in the ancient tradition that also say that fight on was the
first man.
I want to put it very carefully and literally because it's all part of the
argument.
He was the first man to strike silver coins on the island of [inaudible].
Jina coins have not been present in Greece prior to this time.
And the most well informed and a professionally skilled and capable people and
almost everybody who studies the subject says this is false.
There were no coins in the Greek world yet and there aren't going to be any for
a very long time afterwards.
So this is merely a myth.
Um,
I,
I'm sorry to say that in spite of the fact that I am not an expert,
a numismatist and,
uh,
everybody's against me,
they're all wrong.
Uh,
and I'm,
I won't put you through the pain of listening to the argument,
but just keep in the back of your mind.
One day somebody is going to find hard evidence that I'm absolutely right about
this.
And so then you can tweak and say,
Aha,
because that's it.
But right now,
no sensible person has any credit in the field at all.
Believes me there about two or three people.
Maybe that's about it.
Okay.
Um,
another very interesting,
important element about fight on Aristotle tells us he was a king who became a
tyrant.
Then by now,
you know,
the Greek words he was boss allows who became Theranos.
Now how do you do that?
You would,
you would think of a man was king.
And that implies legitimacy.
Uh,
how do you become an illegitimate thing like a tyrant?
And we can only speculate,
but I,
I think we,
what we've learned already about the early Greek kings in those towns that had
any,
was that they were Homeric canes.
They were not really monarchs.
They were not really powerful rulers.
They did.
They did not simply dominate everybody and give orders.
They were maybe the most striking or the best connected are the best descendant
of a bunch of noblemen who were roughly equal.
Well,
if we imagine that's the way fight on began and then I'm just making up the
story,
you understand?
Uh,
then he himself led the,
our jive Phalanx to these tremendous successes,
defeating the Spartans,
establishing Argos as,
as,
uh,
the president of the Olympic Games of giving waits measures.
And Heaven help us maybe coins to,
uh,
the people of the Peloponnesus.
Um,
and then began to act as though he really was the boss because he could,
and people recognize that and said,
you know,
he's not just king anymore.
He has made himself a tear on those.
Something like that would make sense of Aristotle's statesmen statement.
Now it just raises the question which has to be raised whenever we think about
tyrants coming to power in that and a Greece.
Um,
okay,
he wants to be king,
he's popular and all those things.
But what does it take?
Well,
it takes military force because there are people who are going to resist.
And so I would suggest,
again,
nothing original about this,
that the,
uh,
the positive connection with the hoplite army now emerging in the states,
has to be part of the story.
Why would these hoplites support a tyranny?
It doesn't really a chord with their own long range interests or the autonomy
and the independence that are so clearly a part of what it is to be a hoplite
farmer.
Well,
I think the best answer would be that that's what had to be done to break the
monopoly of power and influence of the old aristocracy,
which would have been presumably resisting the changes in society that were part
of that hoplite,
uh,
uprising,
that development of hoplites to movement towards a hoplite community.
And so they joined with a leader who had what it took to make it work and to
destroy the power of the aristocracy and to create a new kind of state,
uh,
with a new kind of constitution.
But the first step would have been a tyranny because that's the way they got to
where they had to go in the first instance.
Now this is easy to connect again,
theoretically because we just don't have the kind of hard evidence that would
make it possible to be sure
to join this hoplite development with other changes that are occurring in
society.
And that is to say the economic change that means trade is becoming more and
more important.
And so is a simple industry so that there are now people in society who by
virtue of what they do to make a living,
to get ahead,
don't fit in to the traditional arrows,
to cry aristocratic system who don't have what they want in terms of influence,
power recognition,
uh,
because there hasn't been a place for such people before.
And the,
the people who are in charge are not about to give it away very readily.
And so they might very well,
uh,
also assist.
Let us imagine the hoplite farmers as being the guys who do the fighting for the
most part,
but join then supported by these other elements in society who need a change for
the same reason.
And that fits rather nicely with where we find the earliest colonies are.
Goss is a special place,
but argus was in addition to being a fine agricultural area.
It also,
from an early time it had the commercial activities.
So that would be good.
But then on top of that,
the next three towns,
I'm going to mention as being very active in colonization.
You're familiar with that from our last talk.
Uh,
Corinth and a little town that I haven't mentioned before,
but it's right next to current.
And surely it was part of the same set of developments that we've described
there.
A place called [inaudible] also has an early,
uh,
Tom Tyrannical family and mega,
which is located,
I should say 60 on,
is sort of to the south and to the west of current and mega is to the north and
to the east of Corinth.
It's right on and around the isthmus of Corinth that some of these early states
that have tyrants come into being just as these are states that are very,
very in the colonial movement.
Uh,
if we go away from the mainland,
again,
my leeches has a tyrant at a fairly early time,
just as you would expect because it fits into the whole picture.
And you don't have tyrannize very early,
if at all,
in places like Athens,
we will have a famous tyrant,
but that will come late.
It thieves will not have a tyrant in spite of the mythology surrounding eat
abyss.
Um,
Sparta of course never has the tiring.
So,
uh,
all of this is sort of reasonable support for the interpretation that most
scholars take.
So you have all of this stuff,
the pressure of a growing population,
new groups challenging the aristocracy hoplites among them.
If you go to Corinth,
the story of the establishment of a tyranny there involves a,
uh,
an individual called KIPP solace.
And the stories that are told about KIPP solice fit pretty decently into what
we've been talking about.
He has specifically called a Poland mark,
which means the war,
our con,
the war leader.
He was a commander of the army in a,
in a conference.
And at that time that would have been a hoplite army,
but he was not a king,
like fight on a,
he was,
according to the myth,
I shouldn't say myths because it isn't a myth according to the legend that,
you know,
it's not really even the lights at night,
let's say tradition according to the tradition,
um,
kips,
the list was a descendant from a mixed marriage between a patrician,
a,
an aristocrat and somebody who was not.
So that,
that's a very comp,
sort of typical historical development.
People who become revolutionaries in trouble makers are often people on the
margin,
but who have by birds,
some kind of a connection or think they have some kind of a connection with the
higher ranks and are annoyed,
irritated,
angry,
jealous,
and therefore likely to take the trouble to seize power.
I mean,
Napoleon,
a descendant from some kind of Corsican aristocracy.
Of course the French thought that that was a,
well,
what does it,
when the word it contradicts itself,
what's the word?
No,
not paradox.
Oxymoron.
That's right.
The French thought it was an oxymoron.
A Corsican,
Arista cracked.
I mean ridiculous,
but,
but no,
but if that was his feeling and that,
that kind of French attitude help,
I think,
explain the drive that he had to get ahead to the green he did anyway.
It keeps,
the list was a one of that.
A group in,
in cars I might point out was an unusual policy before the emergence of the
tyranny because most police,
as best we can figure it out,
they had an aristocracy that consisted of many,
many,
many families,
but current had,
uh,
the narrowest of all.
Aristocracies one family who were called the Bacchae ads,
completely monopolized the regime.
And so that meant that there would,
it would be easier once you've started to make trouble to find help against
them,
rather powerful people who were in other states likely to be part of the regime
but here were cut out.
And so,
uh,
Kip solice joins,
comes,
puts together a force of military folks with some folks who are discontented and
finally a tax the backyards either kill them or drove them into exile.
And then there is establishes his own regime,
which is in fact one of the most successful charities,
at least as judged by the most basic thing.
How long do they last?
Kip Solace in effect,
a died in bed,
leaving the,
uh,
tyranny to his son.
And then his son had another son who became tyrant than he was driven out
finally.
And he was the last of them.
So the kips Dillard tyranny is a very successful,
why don't we know something about
the colonization movement,
which had already,
the Corinthians had already started,
but it really took a real hole in the time of the KIPP lids.
And so Carnes has colonizing quite vigorously in the time of the capsule,
it tyranny mostly out in the west because they,
that's sort of empty territory for from a weak point of view.
And so you will see Corinthian colonies stretching out along the shore,
the north shore of the Gulf of Corinth.
And the north shore is less Greek and more barbaric than the south trail,
which is the Peloponnesus.
And then if you go to the,
to the,
uh,
to the end of grease as far west as you go and make a right turn and head up
into the Asiatic region,
uh,
the,
oh,
sorry,
the Ionian Sea and the,
uh,
beyond that,
the Adriatic Corinthian colonies right along in there,
they suggest,
and I think the supported by other archaeological evidence that commerce was one
of the things that was very important for Kapsalis.
And Corinth is booming from a commercial economic point of view in the years of
the KIPP Salud tyrants.
None of that is surprising.
All of this is very characteristic of this phase Greek tyranny that we're
talking about.
Uh,
in addition to that,
we know that Kipp solice like just about all the tyrants used his power to do
something that the Greek governments normally did not do,
namely collect taxes from their people.
You have to understand that the idea that of taxation being normal would have
gotten a Greek foaming at the mouth when there is no tyranny.
There's no taxes,
no direct tax,
I should say.
The,
the normal,
uh,
form of taxation that existed in the Greek world when it was in its independent
polls phase is simply customs duties on trade.
But the hoplite farmer wasn't going to be taxed.
Paying taxes is what barbarians did to their kings.
Very powerful feeling.
People like that in America today are it used to be called Republicans.
MMM.
Another of course you might.
It's no surprise that kip.
So listen,
his descendants,
just like the other tyrants were very wealthy.
They,
there was undoubtedly wealthy seized when they took power.
There was also wealthy.
They could enjoy from the,
uh,
tremendous,
income that would come from the booming commerce.
Uh,
and then finally taxation,
just put it right smack from somebody who's hands into theirs.
And so tremendous wealth is another picture that goes with this.
MMM.
If you go to 60 on another element comes into the picture,
which may or may not have occurred in other tyrannical towns.
We do know that it played a role in sicky on there.
The founder of the tyranny was a man called [inaudible] Morris.
And again,
one thing we are told about him is that he was Paula mark leader of the
failings.
So we understand that.
Another story says that he was a cook and they didn't mean as golf ea or
anything like that.
I mean,
that was not a high ranking position.
And so I think the implication was he came from a very low source.
We don't know what to do with that.
It sounds surprising,
but maybe it's true.
Anyway,
we get down to the point where one of his descendants is,
uh,
still tiring.
I think it's his son,
Christ,
the knees of sicky on when they,
you want to keep that name in your mind and you want to keep it straight.
There will,
there will be a descendant of that guy who will be an Athenian whose name is
[inaudible],
who will not only be later,
but thoroughly different,
not a tyrant,
quite different from that.
So just remember,
this is close the knees of sicky on as opposed to Christ and these,
the Athenian,
well,
the picture that Hurghada Thomas,
who was one of our main sources here,
the main source,
I guess,
uh,
gives us is one of [inaudible] political oppression of a kind that we haven't
run into yet because it is based on really on ethnic,
uh,
origins and ethnic differences.
Here we see,
I think without any question,
a case of the pre Dorian Greeks have been defeated and conquered by Dorian's and
have been,
these groups have been kept separate throughout the centuries and one was top
dog and the other was the underdog.
So,
um,
what you,
uh,
what has happened obviously is that the part of the tyrants coming to power must
have been a reversal of that situation because the leading forces are,
um,
anti Dorian,
very powerfully anti Dorian.
They hate our gos because our boss is in the Iliad,
the Odyssey,
the great leader of the Peloponnesians and the wrong guys.
And of course our guys,
the Argos in their day is a Dorian city and I,
Shit,
you don't have to go back to the [inaudible] back to the days of,
of,
um,
well,
fight on the archives would've ruled sickie or presumably if a fight on was in
charge.
Well,
they didn't like that they had achieved,
I presume,
a,
an overthrow of that.
So they're antiar Gos,
anti Dorian,
and they,
uh,
they introduced changes in the tribes.
If you go to any Dorian town in the Greek world,
there are three tribes.
They have the same names in all Dorian towns.
And that's the way the world is organized.
So what did they do?
These guys,
uh,
the,
or saggy grids changed the tribes.
That's interesting too because we'll see.
That's Christ.
And he's the Athenian does the same thing.
That's amazing.
That's very rare.
When you were talking about changes in tribal things,
you,
you're getting at the most an oldest possible memories and traditions and
beliefs and associations that primitive peoples have.
So when you fussing with that,
you're really making a great problem.
Uh,
but you'll see in a moment what's driving this sort of thing.
instead of having three tribes thereafter from the,
once the auth average got there,
they had four,
but they changed the names of the old three,
the old three.
Now we're called the,
I'm translating the Greek words ass men,
pig men and swine men.
Whereas the non Dorian's where the are Holloway leaders of the people,
you can see very objective set of names and evaluations.
So you,
you've got vengeance here,
you've got a group long,
uh,
annoyed,
long angered,
long feeling oppressed,
taking out their hatred when the victory comes in.
But once you're past this peculiarity of this particular ethnic conflict in this
town that had such an important effect,
um,
you find that the tyrants are pretty much like all the other tyrants.
They have great wealth.
They,
and we'll come back in just a moment to indicate how striking that was.
They engage in conspicuous display,
which is what tyrants also do.
Uh,
and they are filled with a tremendous ego,
terrific sense of their own importance and self.
The kind of thing that made our killock is say,
you know,
I'm not going to try to Ed vibe with the gods the way these Tyrone's do.
Well,
the story that are routed,
this tells them I think you will enjoy it in his wonderful prose if you haven't
gotten to it yet,
is um,
uh,
Kleist the needs of sicky on now is in charge of,
we're in the sixth century BC and he has a daughter and uh,
he wants her to have the very best husband that there was available in Greece.
Just like your parents.
He felt the same way as your parents do.
So,
but he was going to see to it that was going to work out.
By the way.
He himself was a very significant figure and this again makes him nuts.
So very unusual among the tyrants he entered,
uh,
in,
um,
in the Olympic competition.
And in those days,
and probably forever in the Olympic Games,
I mean the ancient Olympic Games,
the most prestigious,
the most important contest was the four horse horse race,
chariot race.
For one thing,
you couldn't do that unless you were very rich.
So it meant that the noblest and wealthiest people with competing against one
another in this,
well,
he was the winner in the four horse chariot race,
which made him an international celebrity on top of all the other things that he
had going for him.
And so he decides by God he's going to have the best guy in Grimsby,
his daughter's husband,
he invites,
uh,
all the most,
the best aristocratic,
richest,
handsome is most athletic guys in all of Greece to come to sicky on and spend a
at his expense and treated royally all that time to compete for the hand of his
daughter.
And so they all are in erotic.
This reads off the names of all of these amazing young men who come to the
competition.
Uh,
pretty much I think copying a Homer's list,
uh,
of the catalog of the ships in the Elliot and they come well after the bulk of
this year,
it is clear to finalists are emerging.
One of them is called hip hop clades and the other is called Mega Clis mega
clis.
We better take seriously because he's an Athenian and he will be the ancestor of
Christ,
the means of Athens later on.
But anyway,
they're competing in every respect and we're down to the last kinds of things
and it looks like a Hipaa.
[inaudible] has the edge,
he seems to be the number one candidate and he has quite a few belts at the
party when we're reaching the final stages of all this.
And next he jumps up on a table and he begins dancing wildly.
I mean like beyond what is seem to be seemingly dancing.
We expect a young nobleman to be a good dancer,
but this guy is doing stuff that nobody ever heard of it.
And this is making a [inaudible].
He's a little nervous.
I mean,
who is this guy mean?
What's happening here?
And then he flips upside down and begins to dance on his hands with his feet
flipping around in the air,
at which point her out at this tells us Kleiser and he speaks up and says,
son of Thai Sander,
you have danced your bride away.
He lost.
And Mega Clis got to marry hiphop ladies.
Uh,
rather,
uh,
[inaudible].
And the story goes on.
Well,
what are we to believe of that tail?
I Dunno,
but this much I think is clear.
Such a legend does not come from nothing.
The picture is first of all of a man who was fabulously wealthy,
think of the kind of entertaining he has said to have done also fabulously full
of himself.
Uh,
just,
you know,
imagine saying,
my daughter will only marry the very best young men there is and you will all
have to go out there and compete for her hand and I'll tell you who she's going
to marry and who can then act the way he did.
I think that's
a picture that he probably was extreme in all of these respects and that kind of
situation was part of the tail.
So let me just sum up some things.
Untraditional route to power is important.
Guide gs.
Perhaps you remember the story of guides,
these guides.
These was a sort of the prime minister of the King of uh,
uh,
Lydia and the king was,
had this incredibly beautiful wife and he was terribly proud of her.
And so he said to guide is,
you can't believe how gorgeous my wife is.
Guide.
He says,
of course she's wonderfully beautiful.
You can't tell it with our clothes on for God's sake.
He says,
come on,
come with me,
because she says,
no,
please your majesty.
He says,
come with me.
So this guy just hidden behind a curtain and here's his wife.
Disrobing uh,
and indeed she was as advertised
and the king goes out.
Guide use would have slipped away,
but the queen's spots them.
And of course she's totally disgraced.
She's deeply embarrassed as to put it very,
very mildly.
And so she says to him,
unless you do what I tell you,
I will tell my husband that you sneaked in and did this and that he will kill
you.
But what I want you to do is to kill him and marry me.
That's how you can make what could guide you used to.
And so he did.
That's how we became king.
This is not your normal constitutional procedure even in Lydia.
So,
uh,
that guy,
Geez,
fight on,
I've talked to you about already,
the agonies of Meger I haven't mentioned,
but he comes to power by force,
but the use of the soldiers and the same thing is true of Kipp solice.
All these tyrants get there by means that are not traditional.
They have personal power.
Whatever else is going on.
They have control of the military and the military gives them what they need in
the way of command.
They,
uh,
have to have skill.
The founder of the dynasty at least has to have skill.
In order to be a soldier,
he has to have a,
be a good talker to get people to go along with them.
The,
he's got to have talent.
It's not the easiest thing in the world to do to overthrow a traditional regime
and make yourself the boss so that z,
he would have had these quotes,
but he's got to have support out there from the various elements that I
mentioned to you,
prestige from some great deed,
whatever it might be,
military victory or,
uh,
athletic victory perhaps.
Um,
and when he has wealth,
once he's acquired wealth,
he can use it further to strengthen his position.
And they typically do because he introduces something new.
Mercenary soldiers.
It's one thing to seize the power with the help of the hoplites to hold onto it.
You're going to need something more solid than that.
First of all,
hoplites don't stick around in uniform.
They go back and work their fields so they're not around to suppress anything
that needs to be suppressed most of the time.
But beyond that,
uh,
tyrants grow unpopular.
Uh,
you know,
this is one of the great rules of politics in any system.
The one question that's in the minds of all people who have anything to do with
it.
And that is what have you done for me lately?
Any,
any benefit that people might have achieved from the establishment of the
tyranny gets to be taken for granted after a while.
And then why is this guy taking taxes for me?
Why,
why is he such a big shot?
And I'm not?
That's just going to be inevitable.
And so,
uh,
if you're going to keep your power and keep people down,
you can't just rely on the citizen body.
And so tyrants typically hire foreigners to serve as mercenaries for them.
Now another thing is that while these tyrannize last,
it is typical that they should accomplish very significant things that most
anybody would agree we're positive contributions to the life of the community.
They ruled you find economic prosperity is one of the things that is
characteristic of these regimes.
Diversified economies because they support trade and industry and sometimes even
agriculture,
the spread of wealth to new groups cause as much more money around.
There are people who don't fit into the old system in which the land was simply
the,
uh,
dominated by the aristocrats and where there was no other way to make any money
or make any weight,
gain any wealth.
So all of that is happening.
Uh,
and of course many of the kings of the,
sorry,
of the tyrants,
uh,
foster and engage in colonization,
which has all the benefits I mentioned last time as well.
Now there's another thing that is characteristic of tyrannies.
When they make themselves tyrant,
they come to live if they,
whether they did before or not in what is the major city of that whole Polis,
the capitol,
so to speak.
And it's always been a place that had,
would have a special place.
You know,
it's where the,
the,
uh,
Acropolis is and therefore where the worship of the gods takes place.
But it's just worship with the gods everywhere.
But that's a special place for them.
There was always a special place,
but now that's becomes the center of the community.
And as a result,
because where the tyrant is,
that's where all the action is.
People begin to move into that capital city if they leave the land of their
fathers and some number of them,
in fact,
do.
If you're going to conduct commercial activity,
if you're going to conduct the factory work,
and if you're going to be somehow involved in the various aspects of government
and uh,
things that have to do with retirement,
you want to be there and the Qataris have courts.
And so people come to be in the court of the Tyron.
So what you have is a kind of urbanization that is characteristic of this
period.
Well,
if you're going to have more people living in this town than ever did before,
there's all sorts of things you need.
Number one,
no question.
water supply.
How do you supply people with enough water to meet their needs,
uh,
when they weren't there before?
And the answer is you have to bring water into the system,
into the city by a variety of ways.
Um,
any way that you really can,
they do,
um,
aqueducts of certain kind.
They dig wells and have fountains coming from those wells.
They build fountain houses to cover those fountains.
Uh,
they'd bring a water supply.
Also.
If you're going to have these common places where a lot of people live who
didn't live there before drainage is essential or else you will have terrible
disease breaking out.
It's not that they were scientists and knew about germs.
It's just that if you know when there's a lot of people there and that there's a
lot of waterline around,
people seem to die so you don't have to be a genius for that.
There is there our sewer systems introduced by these tyrants which never existed
before and since they are trying to encourage trade,
there was always a place,
I shouldn't say there was always,
but at some point in the development of the Polis there emerged a kind of
central place in the city called the ag or raw,
which was a place that people came together for different purposes.
It looks like in the beginning,
political meetings,
meetings of the Assembly for instance might take place in the Agora.
It pretty early seem to have had some religious significance.
And then over time,
not at the beginning though,
but over time they became commercial centers in our,
if you use the word Auger rock in Greece today,
you're talking about a shop,
uh,
because that's how much that comes to be the thing.
But we need to keep in mind that it is a religious center.
It becomes a civic center.
And it also of course was a,
uh,
commercial center as well.
And,
uh,
so the Agora Ross comes from these a tyrannical periods.
Public buildings are by the,
and for whatever use he needs.
But he might,
he might be building a courthouses,
he might be building up places for magistrates to stay,
things like that.
Um,
and uh,
but also he has a tendency to try to make them very attractive,
very impressive so that people will be impressed with him for having done so.
You,
you're,
you know,
the phenomenon people like to have now they'd like to have their name on a
building.
I'm told they will actually give you millions and millions of dollars to put
their name on a building.
I'm told there are places where they will even give you lots of money to put
their uh,
their names on the bathroom stalls,
but only the,
uh,
the uh,
tyrants in their day.
What have been rich enough to do the kind of thing we're talking about
including,
and this is a very large thing,
I believe templates.
The Greeks had been building temples I'm sure for a long time,
but essentially out of wood.
But now with people having the kind of wealth that we're being accumulated by
these tyrants,
they begin to build them of stone and where possible of very fine stone such as
marble.
And I think we have to imagine the construction of such a building and an old
town like a,
anyone of the Greek city states had,
it would have had a tremendous impact.
This is something I'd like to pass on to.
When you think about the Greeks,
here's one of the places where there so stunningly different from us that we
need to make an imaginative leap to understand what's going on.
Remember,
this is a world that has got no next to no writing.
This is,
there were a few,
there are a lot.
There's some people that know how to write,
but it's not part of life.
And of course there's no paper.
So I mean just to just get more writing out of your life for the most part.
But also there are,
there's no movies,
there's no television,
there's no radio,
there's no newspapers.
Uh,
there were very few buildings
now up suddenly up pups,
let's go to Karnes and suddenly up pops this incredible thing made of stone,
a temple to the gods decorated beautifully painted,
typically blue and red and gold with a big statue of the goddess.
And anybody in town can go by and look at that.
That would have made a sensational experience and people would have been talking
about it in various elements of detail forever and a day.
And they would not forget who it was that constructed that temple.
So that's a,
an example of what I'm talking about.
Beyond that,
the,
uh,
the tyrants were patrons of the arts,
by which I mean architects,
sculptors,
painters,
painters of this,
that,
and the other thing.
But vase painters as well.
Potter's have a very special kind,
but that's not all.
Also poets,
singers,
liar players,
all of those kinds of entertainments which had been monopolized by the
aristocracy to the degree they existed at all would now be broadly more broadly
available.
And the uh,
the time it's took pride in bringing the world's best to their cities and
allowing at least some of them to hear and see what was going on.
When we get to Athens,
I'll be more specific when we have some more specific information about it.
So that is all part of a story that would have made the,
the tyrannies,
uh,
much more widely supported and much not and,
and not so easy to knock over as you might think.
People would have had many,
many reasons for gratitude to the tyrants and would have been very pleased by
much of what the tyrants were doing.
Of course,
the old aristocrats would have been typically very unhappy about everything they
were doing because they had been cut out.
But if you go to everybody else,
their feelings I think would have been mixed because first,
or I don't know which came first,
but they wouldn't be impressed and enjoy these positive things,
but they would also be troubled by something that was counter to their own
traditions and to central elements of their own beliefs and concerns.
I keep thinking about those hoplite farmers and who have grown to be confident
and independent desire to be autonomous,
didn't want to be told what to do.
Uh,
and yet there was somebody who was doing just that.
So this is the conflict that there is.
And in fact,
what we see is a steady decline in the popularity of tyrannies from generation
to the generation,
the founder of the tyranny.
He's probably still popular when he dies.
He did it.
Most people are very conscious of what he achieved and he's a glorious figure.
But his son is only tyrant because he was his son.
It does.
He doesn't come from his personal qualities.
And one is becomes more and more aware of the shortcomings and fewer and fewer
people are interested in the achievements,
even though they may do wonderful things.
And by the time you get to the third generation,
that's the end.
The a generation of tiring.
It gets thrown out if you've made the,
it made it that far.
And when the tyranny is overthrown,
the typical,
uh,
successor to the Thai radical regime is an oligarchy.
I would say
it would include many of the old aristocrats who had the best land and the
greatest wealth.
And indeed the chances are those people would be the leaders of the new regime.
But they would very quickly,
because it was not a monarchy of any kind,
they would very quickly form into factions that would be competing with one
another based on all kinds of different things,
uh,
which would compete with one another,
the leader of each faction for becoming the leading faction,
the dominant figures in the state.
But also,
and this is much more important,
the really fundamental thing is typically almost always the hoplite class of
independent farmer would have participated in this regime.
He would have been a full fledged citizen
fighting would be done chiefly by the Phalanx with these folks doing the
fighting.
The,
these men would be the economic backbone of the community turning out the grain
and the wine and the olive oil and whatever else,
vegetables that they had to produce.
And uh,
being,
uh,
the independent fellows that they were.
And finally they would have played a part in the political life of the city
here.
It would vary from town to town.
Uh,
you might have a relatively narrow oligarchy in which the council was what
counted and that that would be typical council would count,
but it might be very narrowly defined or it could be very broadly defined where
it might include Ali,
all the hotlines or something in between.
But not ever until we get to Athens.
Would you get a democracy?
The definition being that every adult male who is born of a native parents is a
citizen and who has some significant political rights that doesn't come yet.
You have an oligarchy,
meaning short of that.
But with the,
with the,
uh,
variations,
I've indicated currents for instance,
after they get rid of the tire and finally is,
becomes famous in the Greek tradition for the moderation and therefore the
longevity and peacefulness of its oligarchic regime.
I think we should imagine that the Corinthians became a hoplite,
uh,
city.
Not that they didn't have a Rissa cracks who had wealth and importance,
but at the hoplites really played a central part in the picture.
And I think I,
just to raise the question,
I remember I raised it about colonization.
Let me raise it about tyranny.
What were the contributions made by this development in Greek history to the
life of Greeson?
They were mini obviously economic goal growth in the way I've pointed out social
change up to a certain point,
but certainly doing a way for forever with the aristocracy of birth as the
normal basis for citizenship and participation in the state.
And I would go further.
I would say that by destroying that and substituting for it some kind of an
economic basis for what role you play,
they actually opened the door for a form of government that didn't come in many
places but did come and some,
and I'm talking about a Greek democracy.
Let me riff very finally to the question of how did Greeks think about tyranny
after tyranny was gone?
Because it played a terrific role in Greek thinking and had a lot to do with the
way the Greeks felt about their relations with foreign powers,
uh,
and uh,
and their own regimes.
One thing I'll just say in passing and come back to it next time,
and that is Sparta because of its behavior in the sixth century and a little bit
into the fifth,
developed a reputation as being the state that was the enemy of tyranny.
They never developed a tyranny.
And then d they often fought against tyrants.
And that was when tyranny was gone.
That was seen to be a great credit to them and helped explain how did it happen
that Sparta emerged and rose to the level as the leader of the Greeks,
which they certainly were at the time of the Persian wars.
Beyond that though,
the picture that comes down to us,
it's,
it's all,
it will be a double picture in which opposite elements exist,
but certainly the dominant one is negative.
Tyrannies are arbitrary,
they are violent,
tyrants are arrogant.
They do not permit free speech,
which by the way,
the Greeks placed it.
The Greek Democrats placed in a very central place in the important things that
are necessary for a man,
a Greek,
a citizen,
a person who was not a barbarian.
The ability to come forward into the center of political life and speak your
mind and when you didn't have that to some considerable degree,
you were a slave and tyrants didn't permit that.
There was no true political life for citizens.
They were de facto subjects of this timer who himself was an irresponsible,
not responsible to another body,
and therefore potentially dangerous and in,
in very easily could become a,
a,
a dead spot,
which is a Greek word.
Uh,
Hirata [inaudible] uses tyranny as a critically,
well,
you know,
by and large,
he depicts the Picts,
the king of Persia,
who finally invades Greece,
uh,
for in first and for 99,
another king of four 80.
These men are tyrants because they fit precisely the categorization of tyranny
as the Greeks know it.
In a East [inaudible] play,
Prometheans bound Zeus himself is seen to be a tyrant,
and the word is used of him by characters in the play.
For the same reason he's punishing prometheus's for his good deeds towards men,
which make men more divine than they would otherwise be.
Zeus is very angry.
That's because it gave them fire.
Zeus is very,
very angry with him and he,
he locks him up.
A chain is him to a rock in the Caucasus mountains while birds are pecking away
at his liver forever and ever a typical Greek hell of the worst kind.
Uh,
and we are led in what we have of that play to think zoos is doing terrible
things.
He is behaving to radically that is not good even for the king of the gods.
Plato,
of course,
we'll,
uh,
regard tyranny later on is of terribly evil thing.
And because of his anti-democratic prejudices,
we'll say tyranny is the natural outcome of democracy because people can't rule
themselves.
They're not competent to do so.
And it's only a matter of time before some strong violent selfish man makes
himself tyranny.
It is a distinguishing feature in Greek thought tyranny or monarchy.
These are not appropriate for freemen.
That is to say Greeks,
Greeks,
they felt were by nature free and they couldn't be free so long as there was
tyranny.
But tyranny was in fact the natural way of life for barbarians who are not by
nature free men.
So it's helpful,
and this is a form of ethnocentric stuff,
but that the Greeks were very,
very spelled it out very carefully,
thought about it carefully.
And,
and,
and if you said,
well,
why do you say that?
Well,
they would my hole too.
Deep down.
They might hold what we would call sort of racial prejudices,
but I think they would have made a better case for it.
They would have said to be a free man,
as Aristotle said,
you need to live in a bolus because that's the only place it's possible to live
as a free man.
So because Greeks chose to live in polies day are free people who choose to live
as the slaves of monarchs and tyrants.
That's because they are natural slaves.
And that prejudice is very deep.
And so when the Greeks fend up having to fight the Persians,
there's all a lot more going on than just we're being invaded and we have to
defend our land next time.
I look at the great exception to all of the things we've been talking about.
Sparta,
the state like no of the Greek state.